Dwane Casey fired as the coach of the
Toronto Raptors after a 59 win regular
season but the second consecutive season
getting swept out of the playoffs by the
cab's
and the man who called that game for
finish between the Cav's and the Raptors
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
the last game of Dwane Casey's coaching
tenure in Toronto
meaning the grim reaper of the NBA i
Neagle know Richard show is that wrong
should I do that again that that's wrong
I need a completely different intro I
don't want that could catch on what do I
do that when I start popping up in NBA
arena no hold on a sec we're here let's
get it on a second iein you know how I
feel about you okay you know how I feel
about you so I'm just gonna get this I'm
just gonna get this right out of the way
off the top here because I know you're
not on Twitter you don't have a Twitter
account correct no and you don't even go
on you don't even look right do you have
like a secret account that you go on and
you don't tweet but you go look I do
[Applause]
scorpion promos scorpion promos would be
great ion that is great so because I
gave you credit man when when Cleveland
was blowing the cash or blowing him out
you said a clinic in Cleveland pause no
respect in Cleveland now did you did you
just say you call it a clinic I mean you
realize oh I'm in Cleveland I mean walk
me through that I an how'd you drop that
yeah it's not going to be a very
detailed explanation I just I called it
a clinic yes and then within one second
I realized I was in Cleveland and I
thought oh wait that's gonna work I'm
just gonna say it and then we went to
break so it was just very dramatic yes
right to the point that is the
broadcasting version of getting your
checker to the back row and saying
that's what that is
when you get back well are you talking
about King me it's LeBron James sorry go
ahead
LeBron I mean seriously up close and
personal sitting there you have been
calling action for quite some time what
in the earlier what in the world is it
like front row seeing this with your own
two eyes yeah I I didn't think anything
would match
Jordan mania and I came in the league
with the nets when Jordan was playing
baseball so I just assumed when I got
the net job all right I'm just never
gonna get to call any Michael Jordan NBA
games and tough luck for me he comes
back he went three titles I ended up
getting hired to do the NBA Finals for
the world feed for a number of those
championships against Seattle against
Utah and then again against Utah so I
had a good seat to watch Jordan went I'm
huge by the way in Indonesia I walk the
street oh my god did you do the finals I
did I did so I just figured that's it
and that battle be the pinnacle I'm not
going to see anything like this again
I'm not going to experience anything
like this again as a broadcaster and
here we are all these years later and I
don't want to put it on the same plane
because I know we're into comparisons
but the reality is LeBron James is doing
something that I did not think I would
see dominate the way that he does and
then control the game the way that he
does it's all the superlatives that you
can think of every time he takes the
floor it's at that stage now where I
really do feel like we're witnessing
history and he's doing it at 33 rich 15
years into an NBA career where if you
look at the rest of that draft class
guys are either retired or they're
wrapping up their careers and certainly
their greatness is not at a level that
it once was and I'm talking about
tremendous players like Bosh and Wade
and Carmelo Anthony so this shows where
he is at and the fact that he's still
ascending
at this age is really hard to fathom and
obviously it's just an easy storyline to
say well he did it to the cat he did it
to the Raptors again and yet cetera et
cetera but from what you saw Game one
game for now that Dwane Casey has lost
his job off of all of this
what could the Raptors have done any
differently except the proverbial play
better I mean what what what's being
pinned on Dwane Casey right now that you
saw with your own two eyes that could
have been finished yeah you think it
can't it can't just be what happened in
this series it has to be a little bit
deeper we're not privy to what's going
on behind the scenes but talking to
people connected with the Raptors before
the series started a few people tossed
out the idea to me that you know join
Casey could get fired if they get
embarrassed in this series it could cost
him his job and my first thought again
outsider's perspective he's won 59 games
number one seed home court advantage
could win coach of the year in the NBA I
thought maybe it was coming from people
that are a little too close to the
situation and now I realize no it was
real there was legitimate angst around
the franchise around the city and not
just to lose to Cleveland as the number
one seed but to get dismantled the way
that they did clearly was the the final
piece of the puzzle there must have been
some other things swirling up no idea if
that DeRozan benching in Game three 14
minutes to end the fourth quarter please
any role in this whatsoever a lot of it
is deeper dynamic between star players
and head coach and whether or not
management just feels like the message
is now no longer going to be heard from
this coaching staff and they want to go
in a different direction it's it's very
uncharacteristic to see a coach have
this kind of season and get let go but
it goes deeper than that it's seven
years into this tenure I do think he
gets another job the hope would be he
gets one on this turn because he
deserves it he's done an excellent job
improving this team and managing this
roster over a seven-year period yeah
because
I was basically saying you can't fire
the owner demar derozan or drake those
are the only three under fireable
figures Raptors basketball essentially
and you know if you wait till July 1 to
see if LeBron removes himself from the
Eastern Conference equation then you're
you're you're doing Dwayne Casey a
disservice if there's a Bucks job and a
Pistons job open and and any sense based
on you know your travels in basketball
which might be a better fit for Dwayne
Casey I'm doing Casey Milwaukee is a job
that I'm keying in on you honest I've
been a comfo you have a young roster
you're moving into a new building I
think this is a plum job this is a job
that many coaches covet coaches that
have very good resumes but you've got us
sit down with management and ownership
and see if that's a good fit Detroit
right now is a little bit more of a
crapshoot based on their salary cap
issues and based on the fact that
they're committed to certain players
financially for an extended period of
time
there's not going to be a whole lot of
wiggle room with that current roster
Milwaukee is definitely the better job
of the two and as a quick aside rich hmm
like me you grew up dreaming of one day
being in this industry and I told my
parents at a young age I was eight years
old when I told them that I wanted to be
a sports broadcaster and both my parents
were incredibly positive and they both
told me then that's what you'll do in
your life which is really empowering and
embolden when when you feel like it's
something you can accomplish because
your parents have told you that you can
so all these years go by and they send
me to Syracuse and I take all these
steps to get to a point in my career
where I am doing play-by-play of Drake
Kendrick Perkins this is not what I
predicted this is not what my parents
envisioned but this is the reality of
where we are in the world of sports
today well and I was proud to do it very
proud well you know I
you never know what life prepares you
for be handled it expertly if you if oh
thank what were they saying about it on
Twitter
iein oh yeah it caught fire
I I was following along if I remember
correctly ass Raptor 742 yes was pissed
that's that famed Kyle Lowry bot fan out
there
Valanciunas is bot
I think this would by the way a great
fantasy name let's write that down
Valentin this is bought for later on
this fall okay so what's now what's your
scoop now that the NBA and cotton
basketball season is done do you
actually get a break here in your career
I I have an assignment near and dear to
your heart I go to the French Open I've
been doing it the last 12 years for
tennis channel I have retained that's
zero French over that 12 year period
okay I know how to order steak frites
that's the most entire limit of my my
friends I'd say entre called mmm yeah
okay that that's but next time I leave
in a little less than two weeks and
there are about two weeks and then I
shut it down shut it down shut it down
so you got that you wash off the clay
and then you go wash off a deep red clay
that gets embedded into my shoes I know
careful yeah again I love bringing this
up with you iron you always you're one
of those rare tennis broadcasters that
has a soft spot for the for the people
who are in charge of the tennis balls
the ball the ball boys and ball girls
because yeah you've been there right at
the us oh I've been I've been in the
trenches as they say yes I've done the
job I understand the job relate to the
ball people hear about my size so we
have that connect you never knew iron
that being cursed out by Jimmy Connors
got you set for Drake Kendrick Perkins
you never dots tonight and talking back
to Jimmy rich I talk back
I'm gonna admit it I was 14 years old I
was a punk I was a hooligan
and I talked back to him and that was
not a good decision separated by the
ball boy director afterwards and I know
it effect I did not get the finals that
year I had to wait another year to get
the championship match based on my
carrot a don't sass Jimmy so who was the
seriously so you were a ball boy for an
actual US Open final you did that I know
I was for the Tournament of Champions in
Forest Hills okay that was a May
tournament that got all the big names so
it was Borg it was McEnroe it was Connor
as it was Gerald light as it was Johan
Kriek it was Jose Louie clerk it was
Jimmy areas I can go on they're all the
big names I love it do that Elia miss
Stassi was either late very late in his
career I did not get into a back and
forth with him I was smart enough to
avoid that lateness Stassi is the worst
Nastase I love our chats man Congrats on
a great basketball season have fun at
the French Open and let's chat soon okay
you're the best rich no with you two I'm
gonna look I'm gonna look for you on
Twitter I know you're out there that's
I'm Eagle you know Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience